The computer renders a 3D scene by determining how much light comes from each
direction. There are a few elements that go into this calculation. First, we
have to define a world. For example, take this scene. Here, there are many
different objects defined in different ways. Each object is described by some 3D
geometry. It also has some material description that says how light interacts
with it. Objects can also be animated over time. The red cube is obviously
spinning and if you take a closer look at the metallics sitting man on the left
you'll notice he moves. There are also lights in this world which in this case
are not animated. As the view changes, some materials look different as the
light reflects off of them at a different angle while others don't change.
Finally, a camera is also defined for the scene and interactively changes under
the user's control. To sum up, a scene consists of objects, which are typically
described by geometry and material. Along with lights and a camera.